but we begin with new conflicts from the
partial shutdown of federal the federal
government that could continue into
January as more agencies run out of
funding President Trump is now also
threatening to close the border with
Mexico if Democrats refuse his demand
for money to build the wall on the
southern border mr. Trump has lowered
his asking price for the wall Democrats
plan to pass legislation to try to
restore the government when they take
control of the house on Thursday Nikole
Killion is at the White House with the
latest Nicole good morning good morning
to you Anthony and we are now entering
the second week of this partial
government shutdown last night President
Trump had dinner with the vice president
and other advisers who have been key
negotiators in this shutdown fight with
congressional Democrats but so far
neither side seems to be letting up
leaving federal workers in limbo John
Martin an engineering technician for the
Federal Aviation Administration is one
of the victims of the political
gamesmanship that has highlighted this
shutdown it's a little frustrating
because as a federal worker you feel
sometimes like you're you know your
hostage to this Martin is one of 380,000
workers who have been furloughed 420,000
others including TSA screeners and
border patrol officers are working
without pay President Trump canceled
plans to host his glitzy annual New
Year's Eve party at his Palm Beach
Resort mar-a-lago and will stay at the
White House the president has apparently
agreed to lower his demand for a full
five billion dollars to build the border
wall a number unacceptable to Democrats
we gave them our most recent offer we
came down off of our five billion dollar
offer we were fully expecting them to
come back and and and continue those
negotiations last night they called us
and said that they weren't even going to
counter that Democrats say the
president's latest threat to shut down
the southern border unless he gets his
money is not helping the shutdown
impasse the president ought to get over
this syndrome of his television show
you're fired
you're shut down we're gonna walk away
we're gonna get out of your sandbox and
you can't play in it meanwhile John
we'll only get one more paycheck unless
the government opens up soon we should
the Environmental Protection Agency had
additional funds to stay open an extra
week but as of midnight
it began furloughing many of its 14,000
employees Michelle a lot of folks want
this over and soon thanks Nicole